hit start I'll give the wrap or to the
floor Mrs Caliente
you have the floor
[Music]
I'm president dear colleagues today it
is my great honor to present my second
report on foreign interference in all
Democratic processes in the European
Union including this information I often
hear that democracy around the world is
in Retreat I would say that it is an
incorrect statement democracy is not
simply in Retreat democracy is under
attack in today's intervention I would
like to especially focus on two
overreaching games of the report
the first link of our work in the in two
committee with following up the
implementation of the recommendations of
the first report which was approved last
year second we must examine the issues
under the Mandate of our committee this
away Russia's ongoing brutal war against
Ukraine and to build on the lessons
learned our assessment shows that we
have significantly increased our
situational awareness and several
necessary steps have have been launched
and progress has been attained
examples digital Service Act democracy
defense packages on the way
growing expertise acquired however
in the view of upcoming EU elections in
2024 we still should urge for stronger
measures and more coordination to
protect our European democracy
outline some of the priorities from our
report which would make significant
difference in making our Union more
resilient first of all we need to move
beyond the reactive approach centered on
fact checking the banking Etc and
instead focus on resilience building and
vaccination of our societies against
this information therefore we need to
establish a dedicated EU program to
invest in our democracy in a sustainable
way it will not give a solution tomorrow
and it will be expensive but it is
certainly a worthwhile long-term
investment another important conclusion
of our report is that in tackling this
information EO is still suffering from a
fragmented approach without clear
coordination mechanism and goals we
simply cannot afford splintering our
resources when our democracy is at stake
third we should also greatly raise the
costs for perpetrators therefore I
reiterate that the toolbox of the you
can counter measures should include
specific sanctions regime on foreign
information manipulation and
interference
Russia's Imperial War of aggression
against Ukraine has clearly exposed the
interconnection between hostile
information Warfare weaponization of
energy attacks on critical
infrastructure and threats to the EU to
our immediate neighborhood as well as to
the global security and stability Europe
now understands that the Cold War logic
of buffer States is over over today gray
zones in European security only creating
stability risk and opportunities for
hostile intervention interference then
you must invest in closing these gray
zones and supporting the resilience and
integration of Ukraine Moldova Georgia
in our European family and NATO
to strengthen our resilience we must
learn both from our partners like
Ukraine in building resilience and
tackling this information but also from
our own misjudgment allowing to fall in
the type of energy dependency and Elite
capture in the past when I recall the
State of Affairs even three years ago I
am glad to say today Europe is far less
naive about Russia China and other
adversaries
few words about structural priorities
and new challenges we are facing for
years we have been following a country
agnostic approach that threats that
treats all foreign influence efforts in
the same way regardless of hours of
their Source country and thus the aim
scale and the impact we should not be
afraid to call out those seeking
intentionally and in a coordinated way
to manipulate our democracy therefore we
we are suggesting moving towards a
risk-based approach based on objective
criteria similar approach already has
been used in the EU legislation on money
laundering or terrorist financing
immense challenge presents rapid
development of artificial intelligence
tools if so far we still are able to
identify what is fake artificial
intelligence will make creating this
information at scale much easier and
cheaper and much more difficult to
recognize we are waiting artificial
intelligence act with Great Expectations
another challenge is the speed of
decision making process we must face the
fact that today's legislation concerning
consequences of digital Revolution
already addresses the problems of
yesterday this is not only the EU
challenge it is a global problem to be
addressed together with like-minded
Partners moreover I am convinced that
this house in the next legislation will
need a dedicated cross-sectoral
committee dealing with foreign
interference and information
manipulation issues including new
technological challenges
in conclusion I would like to thank my
shadow reporters for excellent
cooperations through this entire process
also the Secretariat and our political
advisors
working on challenges of the Inge 1 and
in the two committees has certainly been
one of the most important missions
throughout the my time as a member of
European Parliament I truly hope that
all of you can support the report thank
you for your attention
thank you to you Mrs kanioti and now Mr
glucksman has the floor
vice president
colleagues there are moments in history
when it becomes a crime to stand by
Turner Blind Eye and we're one of these
moments now on behalf of the committee
on
in foreign interference in all
Democratic processes I would like to say
that for 20 years now leaders in Europe
have been too complacent and naive
looking at sovereignty and democracy in
Europe we've been the victims of
coordinated sophisticated attacks from
outside for 20 years we've been opening
our doors to our enemies there's
financing of anti-eu political parties
or cyber attacks disinformation
campaigns color action in Elites
hybrid Wars against democracy our
leaders have just refused to see this
for too long it takes many different
forms it's on our phones on the social
networks trolls Bots
and uh in Saint Petersburg
there are manipulation information
manipulation campaigns combating
democracy on a massive scale their
private individuals there's chinyogi the
Israeli company there's
dictatorships attacking our democracy
China and Russia this is affecting the
choices that the electorate face it's
exploiting the vulnerabilities of our
open societies and encouraging hate
speech in our societies anything which
polarizes our debate brings in an
atmosphere of confusion and Civil War on
our networks and anything which
undermines confidence in our
institutions is playing into their hands
information chaos which we're now
getting used to is a gift to tyrants and
is fatal to Democrats Corruption of
Elites always precedes the fall of
civilization we have the poison of
corruption in our midst in fact at the
highest level how have we been able to
accept this for so long how could we
have so many heads of state and
government ministers top officials
working in the interests of Russia or
China how is it possible for German
democracy with uh Gerhart Schroeder
working for gas prom only uh
a few weeks after strategic choices were
being made by the German leader and then
when he's a German leader taking
strategic decisions a few weeks later he
walks out and works for this company
France Austria Belgium many other member
states
claim to have a democratic system but to
have also accepted having ministers also
working for gazprom or for other
companies that are part of the Putin
system how can they accept this how can
we accept that so many ministers should
have been
working for China
we can't just have this free-for-all
where autocrats come in uh shopping for
influence and picking people out to buy
them this is a betrayal of our values we
have to combat demagogues and the far
right who are too close to these enemies
we have to combat the financing which is
leading to servitude there are political
parties in Europe that need to respond
to strategically to these challenges
from abroad we're seeing now for
instance that Marine Le Pen in the uh
friendship Parliament has talked about
having a strategic Vision in relation to
a regime but there are millions of Euros
that her political party has received
from that same regime in 2024 in the
context of the war in Europe we will
hold elections we need to defend our
integrity we count on the commission to
start organizing that concerted defense
Vice president I put this question to
you how will you effectively combat
information manipulation campaigns
during the election campaign how will
you ensure that new initiatives such as
the package for democracy will be up and
running over the next few months how can
you ensure that they will allow our
election campaign to be to show
integrity
the digital sector major platforms how
can we ensure that they uh play by our
rules and uh at our service not at the
service of others all the institutions
affected by the elections will have to
be examined and supported in this way
governments of member states too will
need to participate in order to ensure
that the elections will be clean we have
seen during this term of uh the
parliament the life of this Parliament
we were fighting covid-19 we saw a war
return to our continent we saw Qatar
gate and we have been going through
unprecedented times so we cannot be weak
and you must stop being impotent that's
the whole reason why we've been working
together across the border in Inge
across the political uh
uh groups so we count on you we count on
the commission and member states and we
need to count on ourselves too to
protect our own democracy that is our
Noble mission in the parliament we need
to protect this house this house allows
us to express our different views
others see their freedoms Trampled Under
Foot and they're trying to do the same
here we are strong
and we can be powerful we just need to
decide that we are going to be powerful
and the time has come to do that thank
you
thank you thank you Mr glucksman and now
on behalf of the commission vice
president eurova has the floor
the topic of foreign interference is
both timely and important I would like
to thank the European Parliament and the
committee on foreign interference in all
Democratic processes in the European
Union including this information for its
hard and relevant work the work of the
Inga committee and this house has been a
real source of inspiration for the
commission
I want to congratulate the reporter
Madame Sandra for bringing forward this
work which seems to command broad
support across this house
that is the cement to the importance of
the report in analyzing the phenomena of
foreign interference and reflecting the
need for a truly whole of society
approach
the report explores many dimensions it
looks at interference via Elite capture
nationally diasporas universities and
cultural events it includes valuable and
concrete recommendations on sanctions
against foreign interference
recent years the commission and the
European external Action Service have
stepped up their work to protect our
democracies from foreign interference
this was a key strand of the European
democracy action plan
for example the commission is working
intensely with platforms and I am
confident that the recently adopted
Digital Services Act and the revised
code of practice on this information
will help limit the foreign information
manipulation and interference online
the commission is very conscious of the
danger of information manipulation and
interference in the Electoral processes
this is why my proposal on the
transparency and targeting of political
advertising will introduce common high
standards of transparency for political
advertising services for all media it
will also limit the frame the and frame
the use of personal data in targeting
and amplifying political ads
the European external Action Service in
close cooperation with the commission
has continued its work on foreign
information manipulation and
interference the progress made on a
common analytical framework and
methodology in conjunction with the work
on the information sharing and Analysis
Center will significantly increase our
situational awareness and understanding
of suspicious and malicious activities
and cooperation in a whole of society
approach
in conclusion the European democracy
action plan allowed us to undertake
unprecedented legal and other actions on
strengthened resilience of Elections to
promote Independence of the media and
address
this information but you are right this
is not enough our citizens are asking us
to do more we heard this also in the
conference on the future of Europe
as announced by President Van Der Lyon
the commission is working on the defense
of democracy package with special focus
on Covert foreign interference through
interest representation services
the package will include a communication
a directive on transparency of Interest
representation a recommendation on
elections in the EU and a recommendation
of promoting the engagement and
effective participation of citizens and
Civil Society organizations in public
policy making processes
because while we must protect ourselves
from outside interference we must also
build Democratic resilience from within
by supporting member states in engaging
with citizens and civil society and
their policy making processes
the idea is for the EU to be equipped
with a new generation of transparency
tools to shed light on foreign influence
while staying committed to freedom of
expression and Association
in particular the proposed directive on
transparency of Interest representation
on behalf of certain countries would aim
to ensure that companies organizations
or persons carrying out activities for
set country governments that seek to
influence public decision making in the
EU do so in a transparent manner
this law will help us to understand
better the financial flows to the EU
from certain countries that may want to
undermine or destabilize our political
processes and it will help citizens to
understand who is behind what they read
or listen to and in also what is behind
the policy making environment
it would not ban or criminalize any such
activities the EU remains open and
Democratic but we cannot be naive and
actors that receive this type of funding
irrespective what they are should be
transparent about it
let me also reassure you that the
proposal will be very different from
National foreign agents laws proposed
elsewhere such as the withdrawn NGO law
in Georgia or the Russian foreign agent
legislation the approach is very
different in terms of aim scope
supervision and sanctions
together with the president we decided
to take more time to consult broadly and
gather more information in order to
address also the concerns we had in this
house we will reinforce the analysis
underlying the proposal and upgrade it
into a full impact assessment
this is important legislation and I want
to make sure it will be balanced
meaningful and effective
now turning back to the next elections
to your Parliament
we would like to explain how we will
continue our close cooperation with
member states in its communication
activities ahead of the European
elections the commission will inform
citizens about the EU and its policy
actions so that they can make informed
decisions and engage in the European
democratic debate we will also support
member member states cooperation on
Election related matters in the
framework of the European cooperation
Network on elections and the European
external Action Service managed rapid
alert system on this information
honorable members since the start of
last year the commission has been
working with member states on a joint
mechanism on Election resilience to
support the exchange of expertise in
areas such as disinformation and cyber
security in October we will organize a
high-level event on elections with
member states our objective is to
exchange best practices on how to
promote the exercise of electoral rights
in 2024 elections to the European
Parliament thank you for attending for
your attention and I'm sorry for being
so long but I had too much to say thank
you very much
[Applause]
thank you vice president and now we
begin our debate and Mr bilchik has the
floor
thank you vice president
colleagues
since Russia willfully attacked our
neighbor
I believe that no sane person would dare
to underestimate the threats by
malevolent countries I'm only sorry that
the situation had to come this far for
us to finally wake up talking about
threats from third countries this is not
only about the military dangers but also
about long-term silent but targeted
actions that aim to undermine our
society our people and our institutions
we have to react in a fast and
deliberate way
we mustn't underestimate threats and we
need to use the strength of our European
community and I'm glad that today we are
approving the report of my colleague
Sandra canieta and I believe that the
European commission will soon propose
further steps to defend our democracy we
really need those
we need for the platforms that provide
information used to our citizens respect
our European rules we must
prevent some situations that we witness
in some countries that the citizens
can't tell what's true and what isn't
because of too many conspiracy theories
if we underestimate this ladies and
gentlemen we might end up very unhappy
because such environment full of lies
can also impact elections results and
thus also European decisions we need to
ensure fair and free elections in the
next months in several countries
including Slovakia and next year the
European citizens will be voting in the
whole EU they have to vote while being
well informed and not confused by lies
in this information but the elections
ladies and gentlemen are not decided on
the voting day alone a democratic and
free environment is also important to
lead our political campaign member
states and European institutions have to
inspire each other to make our democracy
open but also resilient towards those
that want to destroy it
my questions for the commission today
are brief
when will the planned proposals be
integrated in everyday life and how can
we help the European democracy at this
point already thank you
thank you
Mr shida that's the floor
thank you soon for president thank you
madam president Madam vice president
ladies and gentlemen
often is
democracy is vulnerable and we're under
threat
disinformation campaigns hybrid threats
and so on and so forth these threats are
increasing and will
last until the European election
campaign in June 2024 becoming ever more
intensive and we must protect ourselves
against that the report that has been
presented
will shake us awake clarifying that we
must finally do something but the
resilience of our open living
democracies will be strengthened with a
plethora of measures in the report there
is a long list of diverse approaches
a prevention of foreign party donations
rules on European election campaigns and
party financing that we so much need
Elite capture from
Russia China and the Arabian Gulf will
be stopped um also there'll be work on
internet platforms more arguments and
less fake news is the basic principle
here
our capacities here in the European
Parliament must be boosted and we must
urgently get down to the work on the
defense of democracy package with the
commission and implement it very fast
indeed
ladies and gentlemen
the time for naivety has passed and that
means that here in this house in the
European Parliament we need to draw the
necessary conclusions from Qatar and
Morocco gate we need more transparency
stricter rules and less lobbying in the
half shadows and hidden corners of this
house should be permitted let me
conclude by addressing Sandra kaniente
and the Shadows from the different
groups and the chair Rafael glucksman
thanking them for the excellent
cooperation in the service of our open
living democracy
interaction
keep
Mr Grotto is has the floor
the commissioner Vice commissioner
um dear colleagues in the same week that
this house Rings The Alarm bells on Mela
and foreign interference this
information growing hatred and the
declining trust in our democracies often
enabled by social media in that same
week the CEO of Twitter decides to
abandon eu's code of practice
directed to counter this information my
line interference
the CEO CEO of Twitter had already fired
the majority of his staff dealing with
such problems Mr Elon Musk seems to
think that he's in the American Wild
West well he's not he's operating in
Europe too and there's a new sheriff in
town here in Europe from this August on
and onwards the Digital Services act
enables the European commission to find
up to six percent of the yearly revenue
of Twitter
European commission dear commissioner I
urge you to set an example and show how
Europe deals with companies undermining
our democracy undermining our security
because the report we vote on today
shows how Russia how China how they
vehemently continue to do so if we don't
regulate or act thank you
intervene
thank you
president commissioner colleagues
first I would like to thank our
repertoire Sandra Caliente for her
overall very good cooperation over a
year ago I stood right here praising the
report that should have become the EU
blueprint for combating this information
the fact that we needed a second report
to reiterate says everything
playing catch-up during a huge digital
transformation risk rendering the EU
irrelevant we have countless examples of
how modern force will fought not only
with guns but also with death
information if you are threatened by
tanks everyone knows what this means and
why we need to protect our citizens
hybrid threats are much more
sophisticated democracy should never be
taken for granted it must be defended
malign actors compromise our democracy
by interfering in our elections
co-opting our officials our chair has
mentioned that a crying our critical
infrastructure spreading this
information Russia and China choose
these methods only because they have
high payoffs and low punishment these
equation finally needs to change to
Prevail over foreign interference we
need three core qualities Unity
commitment to democratic principles and
resilience first Unity is our strengths
malign foreign actors have an interest
to divide us because together we are too
strong in this line our group regrets
very much that some colleagues attempted
to use this report for their own
political agenda which might lead to
cracks in our Unity second we must be
aware of dangers of gazing into the
abyss our Democratic principles should
be The Guiding Light
we should not compromise on freedoms of
of expression media assembly or
scientific research in this process
let's win this fight without betraying
our Democratic DNA lastly resilience is
our guarantee for prevailing it is based
on critical thinking Highly Educated
citizens and on our res resusfulness
United resilient and equipped with
Democratic principles we will triumph
over those who wish harm to our
democracy and to our societies thanks a
lot
thank you
thank you president commissioner ladies
and gentlemen to begin I'd like to join
in
the thanks
for Madam carnota for this report and
for constructive cooperation
foreign interference in Democratic
processes is a fact
especially after the brutal war in
Ukraine
and after
they cut the Gate
scandal we have proof that we cannot be
indifferent
and it's good that this report
has been prepared and it's a good basis
to strengthen our democracy I regret
that there are some
statements that attack some member
states for example
misinformation on the rights of the
lgbtq
persons these statements are out of
place here but on the other hand it's
good that we are talking about
counteracting the interference of some
countries China Russia Etc and also
Russia's inter influences in some member
states and
work of some politicians for example
German politicians for Russia we should
conclude our lessons
and
the European commission should also
take into account that one needs to
think out of box
and it's not always good to attack some
member states yesterday
we debated
on the subject of creating a committee
similar to the Inga Committee in Poland
it is completely incomprehensible and
that attack was also difficult to
understand I hope that the commission
will understand that we want to
prevent Russia from influencing
our political life we want to see how
Putin influenced political life in
Poland
but I remind you of the time limits
please respond Frisco next
thank you president colleagues
I'd like to thank the rapporteur
Sandra Caliente
this Spirit of unity I think makes it
clear that it's in everyone's interests
for us to defend the voices of freedom
in Europe from any form of foreign
interference and that includes
the disinformation
combating anti-semitism
is that the roots of a lot of these
extremely harmful narratives which we
see around Europe authoritarian
authoritarianism can be isolated in this
way by combating these narratives in
this way member states can help to build
upon the judeo-christian roots to
be more robust as a society having
strongest constitutional
liberal Democratic Western values this
is what leads us to the duty in Europe
to be more engaged with the rest of the
world President we should start with a
broader concept of the Mediterranean
soldiers in Kosovo including 14
Italians with foreign interference in
that region
two
this has led us to say we need a space
for peace and dialogue which combats all
of the threats to our borders and those
coming to our territory too in the
search for truth rather than political
manipulation
thank you very much
daily
Gracia Presidente Trump and brexit
should have been a wake-up call for
neoliberals but rather than accept their
own responsibility and make amends they
chose to pretend that they hadn't really
lost they found a foreign scapegoat
ramped up the blame game and so the myth
of Russian interference was born does
Russian medal of course it does but the
Kremlin didn't swing elections in 2016.
that is a paranoid conspiracy theory and
always has been every investigation the
Mueller reports the UK Ico reports the
Durham report showed the opposite if
Russia meddled it had no effect
inconsequential it is not an existential
threat to our democracy but the big lie
is too useful to let go Russian
interference is now the go-to slur for
anything or anyone who disagrees the
anti-war movement Kremlin Stooges can
Catalan Independence Putin pulpits
journalists climate actions trade unions
Russian agents every slander more
cynical than the last this is a sign of
the deeply unhealthy political culture
we warned at the beginning that this
would end in tears now with ngos and
uproar over the foreign agents law the
Polish government accusing the
opposition of Russian collusion I stand
by our Minority Report this report is a
travesty to an open Society some of its
Provisions likely breach EU fundamental
rights law if introduced it will be
abused we need to put a stop to this
madness now
foreign
fake information the one that uh
mainstream uh
quasi-journalists are not the ones to
blame
no artificial intelligence is able to
lie as our quasi-journalists
so I think that their jobs will remain
secure in Croatia and in the European
Union the more you lie and the more you
are immoral then uh you will be
named a journalist regardless of the
fact if you hold a diploma or a degree
in just one day you can become a
scientific journalist
the biggest enemy of the new waves
democracy are facts however
day by day an increasing number of
citizens are aware of fake informations
that they read in the mainstream medium
how should we find that they should just
be turned off or ignored thank you very
much
thank you Mr
s
gracias president
thank you
vice president
's report is excellent and it speaks for
itself
those of us who
are contributing to the work of the
committee I think can feel proud of the
outcome this is a vital contribution to
raising awareness about what this threat
and this challenge mean
the report
also meets a need for
objectivity it has recommendations and
proposes initiatives and monitoring of
the first report which was approved by
the committee
we're facing a challenge now
which is lurking in the darkness so we
need to bring light to Bear upon it cast
light into the corners of that Darkness
to find out who is behind it China
Russia Venezuela we need to name names
we need to look at malign influence
Qatar
Etc we need to be aware of wherever
there's a crisis there's somebody behind
it pulling the strings and we have
already had some uh experience for
instance with Catalan separatism
supported by Russian agents
in a year we'll be holding European
elections let us bear in mind too that
once again there will be those who wish
to undermine freedom to take decisions
in a democracy thank you the next
speaker is Ms Bischoff
Madam president
vice president of the commission ladies
and gentlemen first of all I'd like to
thank those colleagues who've done such
a good job of work to try and
let scales fall from the eyes
this was not an easy job
but I do have my concerns when I hear
that the Democracy package is going to
be pushed down the road we know that the
date for the European actions has been
established and we have to have a robust
protection for democracy prior to that
nevertheless like to underscore how
important independent Civil Society is
for a stable democracy
and hence I'm concerned that some people
want to exploit this debate
to attack this independent civil society
and discredit them we have to establish
a framework so that Civil Society
organizations can play their role so
that democracy and the rule of law will
be protected and that's why I'm very
pleased that Miss Universe underscored
once again that our approach is
different to autocratic approaches in
how we deal with disinformation and
foreign influence thank you
thank you
today in kitchen now more than 40
European leaders are coming to express
their support from Moldova but every day
in kishinau Russia is waging hybrid war
on that country using all the means it
has to try and weaken destabilize and
subjugate a sovereign country which has
chosen democracy and chosen Europe
disinformation cyber attacks vote buying
demonstrators false bomb alerts
blackmail attempted coup d'etat
everything passes
a European civil
mission is now helping Moldova fight off
hybrid attack this is an entirely new
Mission and I welcome its creation but
let's not kid ourselves what Moldova is
undergoing every day is something that
we're also undergoing
foreign interference against our
democracies is targeting us so because
of what we are our special committee has
made this devastating conclusion as of
two years ago I'm still not sure that
our Union has moved on from observation
to action there are initiatives but not
yet an overview I impatiently await
commission proposals to protect our
democracy I do hope that they will be
commensurate with the stakes and
ambitious in light of the challenge set
before us
yeah
thank you
you got over that's the floor
dear colleagues commissioner
six days ago Twitter left the voluntary
code of practice on this information the
voluntary code by the way which even
Chinese spyware Tick Tock promised to
follow commissioner Breton promised Elon
Musk that the Digital Services Act is
coming anyway I cannot emphasize enough
how glad I am that there is at least one
regulation but will the DSA really
protect our elections the defense of
democracy package is promising one
directive of on foreign funding and only
recommendations to member states on
Election Integrity the Integrity of our
electoral processes is being tested like
never before in the midst of Russian's
war of aggression against Ukraine and
the global conflict between democracies
and autocratic regimes we need to
bolster election integrity and you said
it yourself commissioner Yoruba there is
not enough in the defense of democracy
package so why is there not a majority
in the command mission to come up with
more than recommendations again it's a
matter of political will and nothing
else and we all know that thank you
thank you
Mr chanitsky has the floor
Madam president commissioner ladies and
gentlemen
this is an important debate about a
crucial problem
I just regret
that it is also
um in sort of
hypocritic atmosphere that it is
happening because we are facing very
important challenges
uh Mr grigsman yes you can do the same
that we do in Poland in the French
Parliament and in other parliaments but
when it's Poland we cannot defend
ourselves from the foreign interference
that had taken place over the years in
Poland
my predecessor beta schedule has already
explained that but still we have
supported your report because at the end
of the day it contains a lot of
important recommendations yes it is not
just about Russia that is trying to
interfere
yes Russia is infiltrating us and we
have to speak about it loud and clear
but please do not stop us from
investigating it ourselves in our own
country
thank you very much next speaker Mr
Becker for results
thank you madam chair
Madam commissioner
house Facebook
if elections don't pan out the way
Brussels wants then you get the finger
pointing saying oh Russia must have
financed the victors or manipulated
things but the two largest cases of
foreign interference in app politics is
actually down to the EU itself first of
all in the Qatar Gate scandal of 1.5
million euros were found at the homes of
MEPS or in in cases plus several million
in Panama accounts figures that
Qatar are trying to buy votes with in
this house secondly
prior to the 2022 Italian elections
also lavender lion said that if there
were a eurosceptic Alliance to that were
to take over government they would start
turning off the tap of money to Italy to
very clear examples of EU interference
in what was going on Russian assets were
frozen on mere suspicion
but it wasn't the uh
the
estate of misunderline that was Frozen
in her assets so I think that's a big
problem
next speaker
report on foreign interference in all
Democratic process in the European Union
of course the author of this report do
not
mind all types of foreign
just some types of foreign interference
and problem is that those are
problematic who are not doing what
Brussels dick stays to them democracy is
only if our guys win
let's give an example of what's done
around Europe there was a recent meeting
in Bulgaria about creation of
governments
and it was also a question of how you
choose Personnel in democracies it was
said that all the people from our secret
Services is are going to be changed
well I would like to know is there any
personal or National Honor in European
Democracies because I'm Embassy should
not choose their personnel in that way
it's the end of sovereignty
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
and congratulations to the rapporteur
for an excellent job of work we now have
an action plan for the commission to
provide effective protection for our
democracy
of course there are still steps that
need to be taken but I hope that
speedily the commission will come
forthcoming with proposals to meet what
the parliament is asking for
if we're looking at
foreign influence it's because there are
all sorts of people are happy to welcome
with open arms countries such as China
Russia
Russia yesterday Qatar also yesterday
but maybe today as well let us protect
our ports our Aero our airports so that
we don't have Chinese influence at that
level with the impact that that would
have in our democracy the reality of our
uh Earth
agriculture sport as well
when you see that there is a very warm
welcome for Investments coming from
third countries who don't necessarily
share the same democratic values as we
do who are exploiting that influence in
strategic sectors but also in energy
and other sectors
strategic autonomy for Europe means
stopping that sort of foreign influence
thank you merci next speaker
content of the second English report
shows that
interference remains high and ever
present the methods and techniques of
our adversaries are evolving and now on
the day of adopting the updated report
we're already facing a new challenge
misinformation and disinformation fueled
by artificial intelligence most famously
the recent example of chat GPT
we cannot be naive technology will keep
evolving and we're already starting to
witness AI created fake photos and
videos that are nearly indistinguishable
from reality as their creation and
distribution becomes easier and cheaper
Bad actors will become more
sophisticated in their use just like
they had mastered the use of fake news
before this time we cannot be just
reactive it is crucial that the defense
of democracy package and the artificial
intelligence act not only cover existing
and known issues but also are
forward-looking enough so that new laws
and regulations will not become obsolete
the day they are adopted the health of
our democracies depends on it thank you
foreign
war and we're not sufficiently prepared
to respond as cyber Espionage and
systematic manipulation of information
targeting of critical infrastructure
there's a an endless list of the ways
and means which are used by these agents
we need to look at the way Putin is
approaching this now finally we have the
second round of recommendations in place
so I think this is good news today that
we have a way of moving forward and we
need sanctions against countries that
are supporting Those Behind These hybrid
Warfare techniques and those
disseminating disinformation on social
media and through our traditional media
there are many ways of doing this and I
would like to congratulate the reporter
for having got such a broad majority in
favor of this text thank you
thank you very much next speaker Mrs Del
Bosco field the foreign
interference is not something that we
can take lightly especially when e
values and our democracies are called
into question in order to safeguard our
democracies we all know that the most
important is to improve transparency
this is crucial this means not only for
us as members of these Parliament but
also for think tanks foundations and the
private companies that we work with
however we need to get the balance right
at times this Narrative of monitoring
and legislating against foreign
interference these turned dangerously
close to calling for the censorship and
criminalization of ngos but without
defending a free and functioning Civil
Society we cannot claim to defend EU
values
Society organization are precisely the
actors that have defended EU values
worked to prevent foreign Russian
interference in the EU and in its
neighborhood countries and put pressure
on us to act to prevent further
authoritarian backsliding if we
criminalize Civil Society we run the
risk of undermining the very values upon
which this Union is built
thank you very much next week Mr broken
the foreign
commissioner
ladies and gentlemen good morning
the main directorate for the protection
of
State secrets that's what it was called
in the Soviet Union
in China they had their own secrecy
directorate and we have our own disinfo
lab in the EU
now how far is the EU going to do it Go
in its Crusade against public opinion
Expressions we've seen the attacks on
Russia today and now we're seeing
external influence being looked at
closely maybe I can give you some
examples from
Dutch ICT entrepreneur
donated more than a million euros to the
greens or an American
philanthropist who donated twenty
thousand Euros to fault
and
donated money to the uh
electoral campaign prior to the
referendum on Ukraine in the Netherlands
are people looking into these issues no
it's purely an issue of trying to stop
people expressing their opinions it's
never been a good idea and it's not now
thank you very much next speaker Mr
Madison the floresios
yes thanks a lot good morning
first of all I think the foreign
interference for the elections in the EU
is not a very important topic because we
have it's not 10 colleagues here in the
room so probably it's not the best
question what you would discuss secondly
I think it's really worrying how some
countries in the world are trying to
interfere to elections in the Europe or
in the U.S but at the same times
on the same time when we are criticizing
some countries
we have to be really careful about what
we're doing ourselves
about interference because we're
expecting that when we are criticizing
some other countries that we ourselves
are absolutely perfect
We are following our democracy our rule
of law ideas and we are not interfering
elections in some countries in the EU
just for for some small example
2019 after election in Estonia
parliamentary elections
we were forming the government with our
conservative party
together with the center party from the
real new group and the revenue started
investigation because they were forming
government please finish your
intervention after elections in Estonia
rule of law that they are investigating
after elections in Estonia
I'm sorry we have to proceed as the next
speaker
we need to proceed with the next speaker
colleague
next speaker called Mr radachi the floor
is yours
when I've read this report I came to the
conclusion that the authors really
deserve a Nobel Prize for this
information and Sakura price for leading
a hybrid War
just briefly
article 105 the EU is worried
concerning China
abducting their citizens through illegal
police station into China apparently now
this is really ripe for putting you in
hospital
China is so population poor really that
they need to drag their population into
their country
frankly some of you have been probably
affected by covid far too madly
you also mentioned Slovakia I don't know
where you're getting your information
apparently homophobia xenophobia
in Slovakia is a reason why two young
people were murdered in Slovakia those
young men were killed by a person who we
really don't know much about
I was in the Army myself there were
thousands of men there I was a judge for
30 years
I am old enough to know that Slovakia
has no homophobia of xenophobia in our
society
this is an insult to slovaks and I will
not allow this this is a pamphlet
that should not be even read
the microphone will switch off
I'm sorry I have to interrupt you the
time
except a blue card from Mrs gregorova
thank you I just need to correct
something
article 105 was drafted
because there were issues with the
Chinese border and it is a
important actually secondly why do you
think these people in Slovakia were
killed
and Globe de planner was it not because
of homophobia and Slovakia are you not
ashamed of yourself two seconds
precisely because our president is
bringing foreign visitors and shaming
Slovakia for 30 years that I was a judge
I was in the Army I I'm old enough to
know this I've never ever seen
they died we don't know why they died
nobody has questioned the guy who did
this but even if we have our homosexuals
and our lesbians and we love them there
are lesbians ah homosexuals and nobody
has the right to interfere in the way
Ali we lead our society and we treat
them
next speaker Mr de Mayo the floresios
thank you president commissioner the
European elections will take place in
2024 against a backdrop of a Russian war
of aggression against Ukraine and with
the pressure of authoritarian regimes
which for years have tried to attack
democracy in general including the
European one where freedom and the
defense of human rights our values and
economic
strengths are things that scare them the
ing report was just the first step in
recognizing foreign interference that is
directed against our decision-making
process by manipulating information and
other tactics aimed at weakening our
democratic governments today more than
ever before with a view to the upcoming
elections we must reject the intrusion
that is an attempt to weaken our
Democratic processes our commitment must
go on with a coordinated EU strategy
against all forms of interference taking
into account the complexity of the
multi-dimensional nature of the threats
and strengthening our I.T security and
the resilience of our community our
citizens have called for a stronger more
credible Europe that we can have only by
fighting these attempts to undermine our
institutions
very much
Espresso De floresios
please
Protestant commissioner colleagues our
democracy and a free participative
processes through which you express our
views are a very precious Boon we should
not take them for granted and we must
defend them wherever we need to our
report on foreign interference shows
that we've reached awareness but it's
not enough to be aware we must urgently
plug the gaps that still exist in our
legislation that make us permeable to
foreign powers attempts to interfere
these strategies are diverse and come in
different forms as must our responses
the report we're voting on gives us
Precious Ways of strengthening our
institutions and we look forward to a
swift proposal from the commission on
this the forthcoming European elections
will be a sensitive step for our
democracy and we must be very attentive
to them path is being set out that we
must continue down structuring our work
in a cohesive way in Parliament too
thank you next speaker
foreign
commissioner
we're voting on this report today
and
if the far left and the far right seem
to be
trembling or upping arms over it then I
think you've done a good job
because
autocrats are attacking open societies
attacking democracies such as our own
and what we can't do is see foreign
interference and harmful disinformation
enjoy impunity we have to combat all
sources of corruption electoral
corruption
foreign interference and a co-opting of
politicians two last year in Malaya
Spain there was a volkswagging scandal
Scandal which was
discovered nine people were arrested
there was an implication that Morocco
was involved
but I don't think anybody would be
surprised to hear in this Parliament
that Morocco was suspected of being
involved because we've been there before
the same as with Russia and anti
Democratic movements in Europe such as
in Catalonia so we need to ensure that
the European commission turns these
recommendations into laws so that we can
defend ourselves we need to defend
ourselves because we know we're going to
come under attack which next speaker
colleague
[Music]
or
um
well
of course we want to play by the rules
but we shouldn't be naive we can't
accept misinformation disinformation but
here listening to the debate we get the
impression that we're talking about
information that runs counter to what
the majority believe we're spending a
lot of taxpayers money to pay for
propaganda for the EU just prior to the
elections
and just like the speaking time today
you're interrupted if you're against the
EU no it's not a problem there of course
if we use the freedom of opinion and
freedom of expression in the EU of
course they don't they're not slow to
impose
fines on you but if you really want to
fight this information I think you need
to do things differently
you need to praise freedom of expression
we're not against the Communists in
Denmark for example there's a Communist
party in Denmark where what we do is we
use the freedom of expression to fight
the nonsense they come out with so that
you should be able to check those who
are against you now we will close the
list for the kidsdi and we will now
proceed with the next speaker colleague
Mrs Ferreira the foreign
thank you president the threat of
Foreign Affairs is increasing in light
of national and European elections and
comes in multiple forms on going in all
the EU the manipulation of information
on traditional media and social media
and attacks on critical infrastructure
corruption hitting financing involving
political players and officials are just
some of the recurrent practices in which
there is foreign interference in
electoral processes there's an
increasing role for technology as is
shown by a tax on personal later and
data and opaque algorithms for online
platforms and this is used increasingly
to polarize and shape public opinion
now apart from the efforts to step up
the Integrity of our institutions we
need
the measures in the defense of democracy
package to strengthen ourselves from the
inside
we need a culture of democratic
engagement and participation by citizens
thank you chair next speaker
thank you colleagues and I would like to
commend Mr
for her excellent report just a few
words on some challenges challenges to
the Integrity of Elections this
information digital attacks this is a
continuous phenomenon the Integrity of
Elections is the key for the trust of
citizens in political processes and one
way to achieve it and to make our
societies resilient is to make a more
transparent electoral
process a good electoral registers and
verified and trustworthy way of counting
votes and also strict controls of
political campaigns we also should
inform citizens because well-informed
citizens are less
prone to interference this industry
needs
um
very important actors this interference
is omnipresent and we should be vigilant
thank you
foreign
thank you I'd like to thank
Sandra and the negotiators who've
included a specific point on elections
in the seconding report I think
elections are very important to
democracies of course but they're also
important because they're particularly
vulnerable some people only take an
interest in politics when the elections
are coming up and with digitalization
and social media there is now an
environment in which elections can be
highly vulnerable we've also noticed
that there is a World Market for
election electoral manipulation there
are a European investigative journalists
who've seen that in Africa particularly
elections have been affected by this but
we need to be careful about elections in
Europe too not only because there's a
lot at stake but the European elections
take place in 27 countries with 27
electoral systems and 27 different
electoral infrastructures all at once so
if you can get in and Target the weakest
link in the chain you could have an
effect on the whole of the European
election so we need to have that in very
much at the Forefront of our minds in
the last year of the life of this
Parliament
I have eight speakers on the HDI list
please stick to one minute limit so I
will give the floor now to Mr Kenneth
the floor is yours
thank you very much president then today
we're discussing a very important issue
it is the foreign interference in EU
member states in my country Bulgaria you
can easily see what the next step is of
this foreign interface interference I
did this
interfering in the forming of government
which is after elections today what we
can see is unprecedented attempt to
block the setting up of a government
between the two political parties that
won the elections this is an attempt
that involves organized crime and
compromise prosecutor's office that is
supposed to find organized crime so on
the one hand you have the security
services on the other hand you have the
fifth column in the Bulgarian politics
against which such Services should be
fighting so all of this is here
happening under the auspices of the
Bulgarian president and his government
place you have to support us but it's
also a warning that I would like to
share with you this is what the lack of
rule of law means
Aguilar
gracias
thank you
president
this committee is examined foreign
interference in Democratic processes
during its uh mandate and it's come up
with highly significant conclusions
conclusions three and five I think a
particularly important linking
technological platforms to the need for
a European regulatory framework and
linking this to defending us against
interference because the tech Giants
aren't really interested in a
pluralistic debate and freedom of our
opinion they're rather more interested
in radicalization and conflict between
users AI
could constitute a complete upheaval to
the way we use Tech here so that we see
images and information which are
completely false and it's much harder to
check veracity so we should be at the
Forefront of defending our own idea of
democracy not only for our own sake but
for the sake of democracy in the world
and that's what I take from the
conclusion service document muches
gracias next speaker
floor is yours
president ladies and gentlemen the
European Union is still a subject to
misinformation and interference put in
new who would
support Ukraine during the war therefore
he wanted to undermine Poland and our
government but you
repeated
those
accusations but it is a German Elite and
European Elites that worked for the
benefit of for example the
um
North stream project we also had a
corruption scandal in the European
Parliament it shows that the European
Union
is fragile so we should reflect
deeply on the question of integrity and
responsibility this way we can regain
Trust of the Europeans thank
you thanks speaker Mr Mariani the
fluorescence
what is the point of this report well
mainly it's to keep in check the media
landscape in Europe in article 33 you
want to control the experts who can
speak on traditional media as it's
called in article 35 you want to
European media committee and I'm sure we
will see it spreading the commission
ideology the ministry of Truth not far
away you want to check and control the
internet more and more most notably
Twitter as a platform in terms of
freedom of expression seem to be a thorn
in the side of the commission you're
saying that Russia wants to influence
the next European erections without
looking at the uh manipulation carried
out by the American Democrats where two
different reports from American justice
system has sketched out here very
clearly that there's no proof of any
interference by Russia in the American
presidential campaign
if you read this report
you should be worried people who don't
share your views are manipulous or they
are
plotting but maybe they just have a
different opinion let us allow them to
have that for a long time to come
we are exceptional and bought our
victimhood and in the righteousness of
our actions when the EU based military
and right-wing cause in Brazil Peru
Bolivia and Sudan this is not
interference in Democratic processes
it's a defense of democracy when the
council imposes crushing sanctions
of on disobedient countries killing tens
of thousands of men women and children
and displacing more somehow this isn't
foreign interference this is about
protecting human rights
this is a lie
because I representative Joseph Burrell
our sanctions are a means of coercive
capacity
the report highlights the need to turn
this coercive capacity against people in
the EU suspected of engaging in this new
and vaguely defying crime of foreign
interference
who will judge if someone is guilty the
council they don't even adhere to basic
standards of due process they're an
unaccountable political body who operate
in secret it's about Titan people
starting to look and see and focus on
the growing threat to basic civil
liberties coming from Brussels
next speaker
Alexandra verdanov de floresios
thank you madam president
Russia's aggressive war against Ukraine
was only made possible because Russian
Society for decades now has been using
does information at the core of this
disinformation is the politicized
interpretation of History we see the
same thing nowadays in some Western
Balkan candidate countries
I can quote as an example Scorpius
discriminatory policy vis-a-vis the
Bulgarian diaspora there as well as the
anti-bulgarian policy of North Macedonia
which is the result of Decades of
communist disinformation and propaganda
one of the main causes for the lack of
political stability in the political
crisis in Bulgaria over the past years
has been the Russian infiltration of the
Bulgarian Elites
the Bulgarian president
is currently not uniting the Bulgarian
Nation he contributes to the
destabilization of our country the
hybrid War Russia has been waging
against Bulgaria and Europe is still
ongoing which is a threat the floor is
yours
Madam president commissioner ladies and
gentlemen certainly this debate is very
important it's a year ahead of the
elections above all disinformation
misinformation
leads citizens astray but what do we do
is the question in this report on
foreign interference we've seen issues
with Serbia Kosovo the Ukraine all with
misinformation centered on them
this can throw elections out which are
democratic acts in the member states
here let it be understood properly there
is foreign interference in all areas in
all member States including my own and
the financing of certain ngos and people
who are spreading disinformation what do
we do we put in place of rules here but
the problem is implementation in the
member State I believe member states too
have very significant obligations as
does the EU to act against
disinformation and prevent foreign
interference in the Democratic elections
citizens should decide last speaker on
my list
thank you madam president
colleagues the need to strengthen eu's
resilience these are these are the words
that have been used in different
contexts in the recent years
the real war that is taking place as a
result of Russia's appalling actions in
Ukraine has further reinforced the need
to strengthen our resilience and
resilience this includes resisting
foreign interference in Democratic
processes in the EU further
intensification of a malicious behavior
is expected in 2024 in the run-up to the
next European elections I hope that the
responsible institutions and member
states will take seriously the
recommendations made in the resolutions
of the Inga and ingitsu committees and
Implement them responsibly as soon as
possible well we are still debating how
to proceed hostile states such as Russia
already taking real actions in Europe to
undermine now democracy the EU response
has so far not been sufficient thank you
thank you very much and now I would like
to invite to the floor a vice president
yorubando floresios
Madam president members it's a tough
task to use two minutes to react on such
a broad and such an important debate one
year before elections we discussed here
about a crucial crucial phenomenon which
is foreign interference and endangering
of our electoral processes so so very
shortly I agree with many of you who
said that we are strong
but we need to be stronger because we
Face many uh some new some older new
threats and and really high pressure
especially in in light of of the Russian
aggression in Ukraine uh increase of
abuse of Technologies against our
democracies and so on and I agree with
Madame Bishop who said that we should
stop only analyzing we have to act and
we are acting I don't have time to
enumerate all the initiatives which have
been already adopted and the plans we
had
we I I just want to say that whatever we
do we have to do it in European way so
to take decisive actions to adopt
legislation to invite the society to
because everybody has everybody who
wants to keep democratic system and
living in democratic system has some
task or some role be it the politicians
here I have to comment also that I agree
with those that who say that the foreign
interference cannot be efficient without
having internal proxies in the EU and I
think that we also have to look at this
so to react in in European way is to
invite everybody to to contribute be it
politicians Independent Media be it
civil society or organizations be it
citizens because I believe that the the
main pillar of democratic system is well
informed and engaged citizen so I think
that it is there is something for for
everyone and to do it in European way
mean that means that by
efficient fight against foreign
interference and endangering electoral
processes we have to guarantee that the
freedom of speech will be
fully protected the freedom of assembly
the freedom of entrepreneuring and that
we will strengthen these these important
principles which we definitely need in
the time of Crisis and I sharply
disagree with those who said
that we are close to the ministry of
truth it's not true whatever we do have
all our all our initiatives on the
contrary uh are directed on a stronger
protection of the freedom of speech so
this is this is from my side I want to
thank you for for your report for very
inspirative discussion and I promise
that the commission will not only get
inspired but also take further actions
in order to protect the EU against the
the foreign pressures and all the risks
which we see now for our democratic
system thank you very much
and we thank you madam commissioner Let
me Give the the floor for the final
remarks to our author Madame de
floresios
thank you dear colleagues Madam
commissioner Madam president I want to
thank you for this uh very detailed and
sorry
uh to thank you for this very detailed
discussion we had here but even during
that discussion it was so evident how
the tentacles of disinformation
are reaching the politicians from the
far right and from the far left and this
is very regrettable and that's why we
are working trying to find the ways to
protect our democracy
what I would like to reiterate is that
you must focus more on resilience
building and vaccination of our
societies against this information to
protect our democracy
and it has been a long journey for us
all and but I'm confident that our
Parliament and our Union has come out
stronger and more aware of the threats
we face and the vulnerable
vulnerabilities
we have so I'm looking forward to the
vote and hope that
you all will be able to support the
report which is not only
mine but that this is a collective
Endeavor thank you
very nice
thank you very much so the The Joint
debate is closed and the vote will be
held today
Now we move to the next point on our
agenda oral question coordinated action
to address
antimicrobial resistance and I would
like first to give the floor to the
altar
colleague Mr Belkin
the floresios
thank you madam president ladies and
gentlemen